there were some 300 migrants in the
Libyan detention camp Abu Issa algum
Buhari is the only one left behind for
those running the camp it was simply too
difficult to have him moved along with
everyone else the nigerian was shot in
the leg six months ago and since then
hasn't been able to walk mattresses
blankets pillows all of the camp's
inventory is going to be burnt over the
next few days the camp has often been
attacked by armed groups over the past
few months
the walls are pockmarked with bullet
holes the militia kidnapped migrants and
then sell them to Libyan traffickers
Buhari remembers the last attack which
was just a few weeks ago
at the beginning of 2016
Buhari tried to get to Europe on a
traffickers boat like the 400,000 other
migrants who risked the hazardous
crossing this year but the boat was
stopped by the Libyan Coast Guard and
Buhari along with the other passengers
was taken to a detention camp more than
4500 Africans have died trying to cross
the Mediterranean this year but nobody
really knows the exact number of drowned
in the mortuary at the main hospital in
Tripoli there isn't any room left for
bodies regulations say post-mortems have
to be carried out on all the corpses of
the deceased migrants including the
children before they can be buried but
the mortuary is overworked most of the
bodies are labelled identity unknown
they keep on bringing us illegal
migrants many of the corpses have been
in the water for a month or so when I
try to move them they disintegrate and
their innards come gushing out some
corpses are so bloated they explode how
am I supposed to put up with this Red
Crescent worker Sadiq Josh wants to give
the remains of the unidentified migrants
a final resting place but many devout
Libyans don't want the migrants buried
in their graveyards so gee I found a
plot of land for a separate cemetery it
lies next to an oil refinery 30
kilometres from the coastal town of Zara
nobody else wanted it really ought to be
making a better job of this we need more
appropriate burial rites deeper graves
and proper headstones sometimes we just
have to bury them in a mass grave hey
what in Miyoko Dominions Hassan so far
1753 people have been buried in jewish
cemetery more come in every week just 40
kilometers from the graveyard a boat
full of migrants has just left Sabratha
to risk the dangerous crossing to Europe
a few possessions have been left behind
on the beach perhaps they will end up
being all that remains of their
passengers